[موسيقى]
بات الطريق الى مجمع الشفاء الطبي طريقا
الى الموت مجددا بعد ان اقتحمت الدبابات
الاسرائيليه محيطه واطلقت الرصاص على
النازحين ما ادى الى خروجهم منه ومن
المنطقه التي تحيط
به تتواجد في مجمع الشفاء الطبي بعض
العائلات الا انها لا تستطيع الخروج منه
وتقريبا هذه العائلات باتت محاصره على
واقع اطلاق النار المستمر من اليات
الاحتلال والقناصه الاسرائيليه
بمحيطه احنا الان متواجدين في مجمع الشفاء
الطبي محاصرين نا خمس ايام لا كهرباء ولا
ميه ولا طعام ولا حاجه وال المجمع اقبالك
وشوف عدد قليل من النازحين الموجود داخل
المجمع وفيش اللي داخل المجمع شفاء فش لهم
ماو خارج المجمع الى متى هذا الكلام
اولادنا استشهدوا تهج جنا مصرين متحسرين
بالمجمع عارفين نشرب ميه ولا عارفين ناكل
ولا عارفين نشرب كم يوم لنا خمسه
[موسيقى]
ايام اول شيء هذه طفله عمرها اربع شهور
انولدت في الحرب هادت امها شفتها ارنبيه
هذه بترضعش من امها بدها حليب بدها بم
البنت صدر بعها تعبان بدها علاج كله هذا
مش موجود في
[تصفيق]
المستشفى
بس
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كي كان مجمع الشفاء الطبي قد عادت اليه
الحياه مجددا بعد ان امرت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الاف النازحين بالعوده الى
المناطق الغربيه لمدينه غزه بعد اقتحامها
المناطق الشماليه حيث تكدس هنا عشرات الاف
النازحين خلال الفتره الماضيه الا ان منذ
خمسه ايام اعادت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
اقتحامها لمجمع الشفاء الطبي او محيط مجمع
الشفاء الطبي ما ادى الى خروج عشرات الاف
النازحين الى المناطق الشماليه الشرقيه
مجددا عضى عن بعض العائلات التي تتحا
بداخله على واقع اطلاق الرصاص المباشر
صوبهم من دبابات واليات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي المتواجده بمحيطه ومن طائرات
الكواد كبتر هذه المنطقه عادت مجددا الى
منطقه عسكريه مغلقه تقريبا المريض اللي مع
المريض الميا الحمد لله والشكر لله مصاب
كان اصاب من راح كان يجيب طحين وتصاب في
راسه وتصاب بايده وبده عمليات لسا وان شاء
الله ربنا يطلع له يا رب ويعفى عنه ويطلع
له يا رب ويغفر يا رب ليش طالعين برض في
لش طالعين البرد كده هيك و تتشمس
شويه ما في علاج وجمعه والله العلاج صعب
والله العلاج صعب يعني في بعد العلاج انت
فاهم كيف نفد وراح خاله يدور له عليه انت
فاهم كيف اللي هو المستشفى المعمداني راح
يشوف له العلاج يعني وين متوفى لكن
متحسرين متحسرين اه والله متحسرين حصار
ماعرف فيه الا رب
العالمين تعم ددت اسرائيل مجددا اخراج
مجمع الشفاء الطبي عن الخدمه بعد ان اعادت
الطواقم الطبيه بمجهودات مضنيه اقساما
للعمل بداخله خلال الايام الخمسه الماضيه
التي سبقت حصاره يدرك الاحتلال ان اعاده
تشغيل هذا المجمع بهذه السرعه يمثل ضربه
مؤلمه لجهودهم في اعطاب اقسامه من خلال
تدميرها بفتره اقتحامها بارت الدبابات
بات حلم المحاصرين في مجمع الشفاء الطبي
ان يحصلوا على قاروره ماء واحده او على
وجبه طعام تنهي هذا الجوع الذي بدا ينهش
اجساد اطفالهم الضعيفه عدا عن ان صوت
الرصاص يمثل مسلسلا من الرعب يستمر هنا
على مدار الساعه ظروفنا جحيم موت موت يعني
الموت ارحم ه ارب ساعات بلفل على ميه ما
فيش ميه فحنا
متحرين من من هان ومن هان متحسرين من
الشرق ومن الغرب من
كله اطلاق نار اطلاق نار وزائف وموت موت
تحت الرعب قاعدين بس الحمد لله صامدين
يعني نشوف لوين نهايتها الشعب ذنبه حاولنا
الخروج من هذه النقطه الا ان دبابات
الاحتلال اطلقت الرصاص مباشره على هذا
الشارع الذي يؤدي الى خارج مجمع الشفاء
الطبي حيث باتت هذه المناطق كما تشاهدون
محاص من الطائرات ومن الدبابات
الاسرائيليه هذه غاره ايضا غاره بمحيط
مجمع الشفاء الطبي هزت اركان المجمع وكسرت
شبابيكه بالكامل يعني هذه الغاره قريبه
جدا من مجمع الشفاء الطبي هذا هو حال مجمع
الشفاء الطبي حرب
دروس
[تصفيق]
حصلنا هنا في الشفاء وماحدش قادر يطلع
لبره حتى كل كل هذا مش قادر نطلع حتى
الماء مش موفر الشراب مش موفر حتى احنا
عننا مي الي انقطعت عنا كثير ومنا مساعدات
حتى الاكل مش لاقيينه احنا بنا دعم الماء
اللي انا حتى صار معي جفاف اكثر من مره
وانزل اخذ ابر من كتر ان فيش قله ماء انا
عايشه بدي ميه ك بتزني ميه انا بدي اكل
بدي اشرب رسالتي للعالم للامم المتحده
لاوروبا لكل العالم وعربيه و لكل الرؤسا
العربيه يطلعونا بنظره رحمه ياماك مش
قادرين يحلوها بكف عالم وين مجتمع الدوله
وين حقوق الانسان احنا بدنا نعيش زي احران
العالم في شكلنا ست ايام في الشفا لا في
ميه ولا اكل ولا شرب مش حرام ايش ب يا
عرب